the one thing that I always feel sort of
I would like to always express is that
what I appreciated about the Nobel Prize
in particular and what I think is
absolutely essential for I'm just for
science not only science but actually
also for our societies and maybe even
for civilization in a broad sense is
that science operates purely or should
operate purely by the ideal of figuring
out what the truth is about real things
and but it's done by humans and humans
are by the very nature never always
truthful and so I really appreciate
about the Nobel Prize that historically
it has always been unbelievably well
done in the sense that the selection was
I can't say this about my own case but
about previous cases would really based
on on scholarship and I think that that
is an enormous achievement and I think
that that's really what constitutes the
value of the price and and I can only
congratulate to know well I don't know
actually who does this I can only
congratulate them on doing it so true
such such a wonderful job